[Music]
foreign
and I'm excited to tell you about the
top three reasons that you should take
the causal inference with our workshop
at posicom22 3
the first reason is that in this
Workshop you will learn modern and
elegant ways to perform causal inference
using tools like tidy models and the
Tidy verse it's contrast with some more
traditional ways of teaching causal
events that are very heavily theoretical
or use more Legacy programming
approaches
the second reason Builds on the first
reason we have some fun coding elements
in this Workshop such as performing
causal inference with group buy and
summarize I bet you didn't think that
was possible but in this Workshop you'll
find out how the third reason of course
is the people Malcolm Barrett has years
of experience running this Workshop
successfully and I'm sure you'll enjoy
it as for myself it's my first year with
the workshop but I'm excited to come
share my experience as a student of
causal inference at Harvard School of
Public Health later a faculty member in
Academia studying causal inference and
its applied methods and now as a
practitioner in the clinical trials
space
and of course there's you
together we'll form a small community
over two days of causal inference
enthusiasts using R to implement it I'm
really excited to see you there
foreign
[Music]